R
IN UKRAINE.
IO
NDENT SAM
KILEY.>> Reporter:SI
HYPERV
THES
RECONNAISSANCE SOLDIERS RELIVINO
MA VETD
CAMPGN AND
SYRIA.NOW THEY WORK  THE
LINES, DEEP INTO ENEMY TERRITOR.
>> WE WOULD GET SO CLOSE TO THE
RUSSIANS THAOULD HEAR TH
TALKING.
WE COULD HEAR THEM COOKING THEIR
FOOD ANDE WOOD TO
ANDREY'S MILITALL.S.
AND TH'S WHAT THEI
GETTING SPOTTED REG CAMPAIGNCAP.
BUT THEY MAKE OFWITH A
OF STOLESSIAN
TECHNOLOGY, ING TONT
RATION OF A RUSSIANTTHE SURREND
SENIOR SERGEANT.
PARATROOPER ABANDONED
IS THAT eporter: HE EM HE'S
BET FOR SIX DAYS.
THEN THE U
N OUT  HERE.Y'VE BEEN
ING HEHE SAYS. BUT SAFE.TRIKES
ABANDONED POSITIONS WERE A
ADE E DURING T
AUTUMN.
STINGER ANTIAIRCRAFT A
MIXED BLESSING.
MISSING WITH ONE ATTRACT
R  TTHE ION FROM TIRN ISND HUNT.
RUSSIANS TO RUN.
AND SUDDENLY ACROSS THWHOLE  TH
RUN.IN CHASING THE RUSSIANS OUT,
CRS HAVE OFTEN EN HIT WITTID AR
MO
SURVIVAL OF GIGGLING RELIEF.
WARDS, THESAY, ARE
>> OF COURSE WHEN I SEEN
VILLAGERS, THEY SEEN THE
RAHEIRST
TIME IN WHO KNOWEIGHT MONTHSLEAE
Y-
CRYING THANKING US FOR HELP